mes chers collègues mais beaucoup sont
dans l'hémicycle enfin
après avoir entendu la semaine dernière
les groupes engie et total énergie notre
mission d'information reçoit aujourd'hui
le groupe EDF en particulier sa filiale
hydrogène alors
et nous avons le plaisir de recevoir cet
après-midi madame Christelle Rouyer
directrice générale de imanix
Monsieur Arthur parenti responsable des
affaires publiques de cette
filiale et Monsieur Bertrand
Lethiec directeur des affaires publiques
du groupe EDF alors je rappelle que
cette réunion est captée elle est
diffusée en direct sur le site du Sénat
sur lequel elle pourra être ensuite
consulter en vidéo à la demande Madame
la Directrice Générale messieurs notre
mission d'information comprend des
membres issus des différentes
commissions du Sénat et représentent
l'ensemble des groupes politiques qui
composent le Sénat le développement des
filières de biocarburant de carburant
synthétique durable et d'hydrogène vert
représente un enjeu important pour
permettre à la France à l'Union
européenne d'atteindre l'objectif de
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2050 mais
aussi pour notre souveraineté et la
compétitivité de notre économie après
avoir entendu de nombreux acteurs
publics qui se penchent sur les
stratégies à mettre en oeuvre des
centrales de réflexion désorganismes de
recherche il nous importe d'avoir la
vision des industriels et singulièrement
des producteurs d'énergie
premièrement pour comprendre comment
votre groupe s'adapte à l'ambition
européenne qui se dessine qui
constituent à certains écarts véritable
changement de paradigme dans le domaine
de la mobilité
deuxièmement pour apprécier ce que
représente les perspectives de
développement des biocarburants des
carburants de synthèse et d'hydrogène
vert
dans le portefeuille d'activité du
groupe comme EDF mais aussi pour
analyser ce qui peut aujourd'hui freiner
le développement de ces filières que ce
soit sur le plan réglementaire sur le
plan technique ou en termes
d'accompagnement fiscal ou financier
nous avons bien conscience que la France
et l'Union européenne n'évoluent pas
dans une bulle isolée du reste du monde
et que nous devons faire face à des
stratégies de développement industriels
très ambitieux voire agressive de la
part de certains états je pense
évidemment à l'IRA américain
nous comprenons
des stratégies qui se dessinent que
l'hydrogène vert et les carburantes
synthèse sont appelés à contribuer de
manière significative à décarboner un
certain mode de transport et en
particulier la mobilité lourde plus
personne
plusieurs personnes auditionnées ont
toutefois souligné la rareté des
ressources disponibles
la mission d'information ainsi était
alerté sur les tensions pouvant exister
entre les besoins en électricité
nécessaire pour atteindre les objectifs
de décarbonation fixés par l'Union
européenne du part et la capacité de
produire à hauteur des besoins c'est
électricité en matière décarbonée
d'autres parts sur ce plan le point de
vue du groupe EDF nous intéresse
évidemment tout particulièrement tout
comme votre analyse concernant les
débats en cours au niveau de l'Union
européenne pour prendre en compte de
manière adéquate la contribution de
l'hydrogène des carbonées au même titre
que l'hydrogène renouvelable vous
pourrez également nous exposer la
manière dont vous appréciez les mérites
comparés des stratégies françaises et
allemandes de développement de la
filière hydrogène puisque vous possédez
une filière en Allemagne
notre rapporteur monsieur Vincent capot
canelas qui est à l'origine de cette
mission vous adressez un questionnaire
qui peut vous servir de guide mais ce
qui nous importe dans votre propos
limanaire c'est évidemment votre vision
stratégique des enjeux que nous abordons
à travers cette mission je passerai
ensuite la parole à notre rapporteur
puis à l'ensemble de mes collègues afin
qu'ils puissent vous relancer et vous
poser un certain nombre de questions
vous pouvez bien évidemment nous
transmettre ultérieurement des réponses
écrites aux questions qui vous ont été
adressées par notre rapporteur madame
Rouillet je vous cède la parole pour une
quinzaine de minutes merci
à chaque fois que vous pourrez la parole
faut bien mettre le micro très bien
merci parfait merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
merci beaucoup pour cette opportunité
effectivement qui nous est donnée de
pouvoir nous exprimer en tant que
directrice générale
est fondatrice de aynamics
effectivement dans le cadre de cette
édition merci pour nous de partager avec
vous la vision du groupe EDF quant au
développement de la filière française de
production de carburant synthétiques
durable et d'hydrogène bas carbone
en effet nous sommes effectivement
convaincus
du rôle majeur
dont dispose l'hydrogène et ses dérivés
on y reviendront pouvant également être
qualifié de carburant de synthèse vous
l'avez mentionné monsieur le Président
selon leur utilisation dans la
décarbonation de notre économie et en
particulier
l'industrie et les transports lourds à
ce titre je salue le caractère englobant
de cette mission d'information qui bien
évidemment au-delà des seuls
biocarburants alternatifs
qui loin d'être exclusif les uns des
autres sont avant tout complémentaires
face à l'immense des filles
de la réduction des émissions
concernant les transports de longue
distance c'est pour ça que le groupe EDF
a annoncé en avril 2022 sont plan
hydrogène qui à l'image des autres plans
du groupe comme le plan solaire le plan
stockage électrique est un véritable
plan industriel qui mobilisera jusqu'à 3
milliards d'euros d'investissements avec
l'objectif de développer d'ici 2030 près
de 3 gigawatts de projet d'hydrogène
électrolytique c'est-à-dire
produit à partir de l'électrolyse de
l'eau
grâce à de l'électricité renouvelable et
vous l'avez mentionné tout à l'heure bac
carbone c'est important cet hydrogène
servira à bicarbonée les secteurs de
l'électrification les secteur pardon ou
l'électrification directe s'avère encore
difficile on y reviendra plus précisé
plus précisément tout à l'heure donc
difficile technologiquement voire même
parfois impossible
c'est notamment le cas
pour certaines industries lourdes
aujourd'hui consommatrices d'hydrogène
carbonée je pense notamment à la chimie
au raffinage mais aussi pour la mobilité
lourde ou le véhicule à batterie ne peut
assurer le même service que celui de
l'hydrogène en complément
les carburants de synthèse apparaissent
comme particulièrement prometteur pour
des carboner le transport aérien et
maritime nous pourrons y revenir au
cours de cette allocution
ce plan hydrogène est l'aboutissement de
plusieurs décennies de recherche et
développement afin de maîtriser la
chaîne de valeur de l'hydrogène et la
technologie de l'électrolyse avec
notamment une prise de participation du
groupe EDF dans la société française
d'électrolyseur j'ai nommé la société
McPhee
cette action c'était effectuée en 2017
cette montée en compétence et la
maturité technologique du procédé ont
ensuite motivé très très vite la
création en 2019 vous l'avez précisé
tout à l'heure monsieur le Président
dynamics qui la filiale dédié à la
production et à la commercialisation
d'hydrogène bakarbonne en 2021 notre
premier actif de production c'est à dire
deux ans plus tard
de production et de commercialisation
d'hydrogène bas carbone a été le projet
à Auxerre en partenariat avec
lagglomération de l'eau ces rois pour
alimenter les premiers bus
de l'agglomération de l'océroi et demain
des camions et sous réserve des
résultats de l'appel d'offres que nous
avons aujourd'hui en cours certaines
régions comme la Bourgogne Franche-Comté
se dotera de train hydrogène une
deuxième station
sera mise en service à Belfort
cet été ou plus exactement à l'automne
et une dizaine nous pourrons parler plus
précisément si vous le souhaitez d'ici
ces premiers petits objets petit projet
reposant majoritairement sur des usages
publics
sont essentiels
pour asseoir la maîtrise de
l'électrolyse de l'eau et de manière
très opérationnelle afin de pouvoir
aborder les grands projets industriels
de demain
et c'est le deuxième volet le deuxième
secteur d'activité que nous abordons
aujourd'hui également en divisant
peut-être deux catégories d'une part la
substitution d'hydrogène carbonée
actuellement consommée en temps que
matière première dans l'industrie par de
l'hydrogène électrolytique c'est ce que
nous développons par exemple avec le
chimiste Boréalis dans la plateforme de
industriel de
Ottmarsheim
pour décarboner la production d'ammoniac
servante à la fabrication d'engrais
agricoles
d'autre part la valorisation des
émissions de CO2 que l'on peut qualifier
de fatale c'est-à-dire finalement
inhérente à certains procédés
industriels qui ne peuvent faire
autrement comme par exemple la
décarbonation du calcaire pour fabriquer
du séma dans ce cas là le CO2 est capté
à la sortie des cheminées d'une
cimenterie pour ensuite être recombinés
à l'hydrogène afin de produire des
molécules de synthèse pouvant être
utilisés comme carburant dans les
navires ou les avions j'ai parlé ici de
méthanol
c'est ce que nous développons avec le
cimentier Vicat français à Montalieu
pour produire du méthanol de synthèse à
destination du secteur maritime
notamment pour des gros armateurs j'ai
nommé notamment
CMA-CGM et pas que
les objectifs que ces données la France
en matière d'hydrogène sont
particulièrement ambitieux avec 6,5
gigawatts d'électrolyse installé en 2030
vous l'avez mentionné monsieur le
Président en parallèle l'Union
européenne a considérablement relevé ses
objectifs avec le paquet fit for
fifty-five suite à la guerre en Ukraine
que ce soit en matière d'hydrogène
renouvelable consommée de décarbonation
d'industrie mais aussi des transports en
particulier le maritime et
l'aéronautique
ces objectifs essentiels en vue de la
neutralité carbone 2050 nous oblige
à accélérer dans le développement de
cette filière
mais cela ne peut se faire que sur la
base de certains prérequis encore
aujourd'hui non sécurisés
tout d'abord il est fondamental de
dépasser le clivage entre les
différentes couleurs de l'hydrogène
électrolytique
les besoins que ce soit en hydrogène ou
en carburant de synthèse sont massifs
toutes les sources d'électricité
décarbonées doivent pouvoir contribuer à
leur production pour atteindre nos
objectifs toutes les sources
d'électricité des carbonées
nous appelons donc un traitement
équivalent
dans les politiques de soutien basé sur
l'empreinte carbone de la molécule
produite quelle que soit
quel que soit l'origine de l'électricité
utilisée la France dispose en effet d'un
avantage majeur par rapport à ses
voisins
l'Allemagne notamment pour ne pas les
nommer qui est l'accès à un mix
électrique largement décarbonée
ce qui permet aux électrolyseurs d'être
accordé au réseau électrique afin de
produire sans intermittence
de l'hydrogène en large volume qui soit
à la fois compétitif et vertueux d'un
point de vue environnemental
c'est très important
de la même manière que les volumes
d'électricité requis seront très
importants pour répondre à nos besoins
en hydrogène effectivement les objectifs
européens de décarbonation du maritime
et de la héro nautique vont entraîner
une très forte demande en carburant de
synthèse qui nécessite également du CO2
pour leur fabrication il apparaît alors
comme particulièrement pertinent de
valoriser les émissions de CO2 fatales
comme celle des cimenteries
dont les fumées très concentrées permet
de réduire le coût du captage mais
surtout pour lesquels il n'existe pas
d'autres alternatives de décarbonation
en effet la grande majorité des sites
symétries français sont situés dans les
terres évidemment à proximité des
réserves de calcaire
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils n'ont
pas forcément accès aux futurs
infrastructures de transport du CO2 vers
des cavités géologiques pour être
stockées de manière permanente malgré
cela l'Union européenne souhaite limiter
à l'avenir la possibilité de valoriser
le CO2 uniquement au CO2 dit biogénique
par opposition au CO2 industriel ce
gisement de CO2
issus de la combustion de biomasse étant
plus diffusé par rapport à la demande
nous préconisons
la mise en place d'une distinction
juridique entre tous et audio
industriels et CO2 fatal afin de pouvoir
valoriser ce dernier
enfin
et j'en ai presque terminé le
déploiement des mécanismes de
financement public doit être également
accéléré
les projets sont là
chez nous ils sont là prêt à avancer
mais les mesures de soutien prévues par
leur ordonnance hydrogène de février
2021 se font encore attendre et les
délais d'instruction des projets
pionniers soumis pour validation auprès
de la Commission européenne prenne
beaucoup beaucoup de retard par rapport
au calendrier inotion je pourrais vous
donner des projets je pourrais vous
donner des délais ainsi c'est la
stratégie nationale hydrogène cible les
bonnes priorités il est vrai il dispose
d'une enveloppe budgétaire conséquente
il est vrai aussi
l'enjeu aujourd'hui est de concrétiser
ses ambitions en engageant pardon les
crédits déjà annoncés
nous constatons en effet que la France
précurseur sur l'hydrogène est
aujourd'hui rattrapé par des pays qui
malgré leur retard initial ont su donner
plus de visibilité à la filière en
finalisant rapidement leur politique
publique de soutien
pour conclure monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur je dirais
simplement
que nous avons en France toute la chaîne
de valeur pour réussir
dans le développement de cette filière
stratégique qui apparaît comme essentiel
à la souveraineté énergétique européenne
et pour ce faire
nous devons accélérer sur la
stabilisation du cadre réglementaire et
l'engagement des financements publics
je me tiens à votre disposition dès à
présent pour toutes les questions que
vous voudrez bien nous poser merci de
votre attention
merci
monsieur le rapport
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice Générale merci d'avoir votre
propos qui était un plaidoyer dynamique
et fort pour pour l'hydrogène d'abord un
premier point de principe c'est que
quand on pense à EDF on se dit le groupe
va plutôt nous dire qu'il faut procéder
par électrification des transports et de
l'industrie et là vous allez un rôle qui
est sous la filiale qui est un peu en
contrepoint alors comment vous vous
justifiez cette contradiction apparente
qui peut quelque part nous réjouir
puisque on regarde l'ensemble des
hypothèses et d'ailleurs on est plutôt
sur l'hypothèse qui sont pas celles de
l'électrification dans cette mission
dans sa tombe fort bien pour nous mais
malgré tout voilà je me dois quand même
de vous poser cette question là et puis
souvent on est entendre ensemble
d'experts qui nous disent
l'hydrogène pourquoi pas ça peut être un
complément à l'électrification en tout
cas en matière de transport parce que on
a un sujet c'est la capacité à avoir
suffisamment d'énergie électrique
pour pouvoir faire de l'hydrogène en
particulier et puis notamment vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure quand on
parle de mobilité mobilité lourde
on a des points de vue qui sont quand
même assez balancés sur les poids lourds
où on nous dit après tout finalement les
poids lourds peuvent très bien
être
sur une solution de l'électrification
alors vous avez un point de vue qui est
qui est effectivement différent mais on
a reçu encore un certain nombre
d'experts qui sont plutôt sur l'idée de
non oublier l'hydrogène question que je
dois vous poser aussi sur la partie
sécurité sur tes qu'est-ce qu'il en est
mais il y a toujours ce fameux rapport
de la Cour des comptes
et du Conseil enfin de l'inspection
générale de l'environnement et du
développement durable je crois que c'est
simple je parle de mémoire qui qui avait
quand même quelques réserves est-ce que
vous les faites votre sur la partie
électrolyseur j'ai entendu votre propos
avec beaucoup d'intérêts donc vous avez
investi vous avez pris une participation
dans une filière je crois en 2017 alors
une société qui est devenue notamment
vous êtes actionnaire si ce si ça n'est
votre filiale comment vous voyez cette
multiplication des électrolyseurs on
parle de giga Factory on
évoque aussi des difficultés à les
développer
je crois que votre expérience nous sera
nous sera utile sur ce point
je note aussi que sur les transports
vous avez plaidé pour les bus on cite un
expérience de d'Auxerre sur le train
hydrogène quelle est la capacité de
votre point de vue de régler les
problèmes de décarbonation pour ces
modes de transport sur le train en
particulier ou est-ce que vous allez
être avec SNCF
et est-ce que vous voyez là une solution
pour les petites lignes
est-ce que vous voyez une concurrence
entre hydrogène et
carburant de synthèse alors sachant que
vous avez
de mon point de vue habitement mais les
deux mais comment vous gérez ces deux
ces deux hypothèses est-ce qu'il y a une
contradiction ou est-ce que tous ceux
tout cela procède de la même logique
après tout il faut l'électricité dans
les deux cas voilà quelques éléments
d'abord j'aurais peut-être d'autres
sujets avec peut-être une interrogation
encore sur je vous avais dit sur les
projets qui sont en retard mise en
oeuvre de projet on a déjà entendu ce
type de points lorsque vous pouvez
publiquement ici ou bien après nous nous
renseigner un petit peu plus là dessus
sachant que
on entend parfois que les appels à
projets tarde et on a entendu y compris
dans des beaux départements qui sont
ceux de mon Président celui de mon
président des acteurs nous dire qu'ils
sont prêts à développer l'hydrogène et
que l'appel à projet n'est pas i de
financement là-dessus c'est un point qui
qui peut compter merci
pardon merci monsieur le rapporteur
effectivement alors
première chose
la meilleure des électrifications reste
l'électrification directe
l'hydrogène va intervenir quand il n'y a
pas forcément d'autres possibilités je
vais distinguer les deux choses entre la
mobilité et l'industrie d'abord la
mobilité quand
un
bus ou un véhicule a besoin d'autonomie
je vais vous donner quelques chiffres
pour que ça soit un petit peu plus
parlant
dans un mode opératoire qui implique de
ne pas devoir se charger pendant toute
une nuit
et avec un nécessité d'énergie parce que
le transport en question nécessite plus
d'énergie embarquée et bien dans ces
cas-là l'hydrogène va davantage
faire
sens que les la batterie je m'exprime
pour une distance de plus de 300 km
d'une part pour un mode opératoire des
chauffeurs qui ont besoin de se charger
en quelques minutes
et pour une énergie embarquée importante
dans ces cas là il est préférable
d'avoir de l'hydrogène plutôt que la
batterie électrique et typiquement nous
travaillons nous en
total collaboration avec les opérateurs
en question que ça soit donc les
sociétés diverses Transdev qui est au
lit Saint-Co de manière à pouvoir
optimiser
la fourniture de l'hydrogène au moment
en fonction effectivement de la
contrainte de leurs opérateurs de leur
de leur chauffeur de bus notamment
pour ce qui concerne les les camions et
bien nous sommes sur quelque chose
d'assez identique à l'instar des bus qui
pour certains d'entre eux il y aura dans
des communes dans des agglomérations
des bus électriques comme des bus
hydrogène les deux en fait seront
concomitantes oserais-je dire tout ça
dépendra de la ligne de bus en question
et bien pour les camions c'est
exactement la même chose dès lors où
vous aurez en fait un temps d'autonomie
extrêmement important la batterie en
fait ne pourra plus faire le job et
c'est la raison pour laquelle hydrogène
est plus pertinente
raison pour laquelle nous développons
nos propres projets en lien d'abord avec
la puissance publique qui est souvent
la Communauté de Communes la communauté
d'agglomération tout simplement parce
que elles ont selon la ligne directive
européenne obligation d'un 0 carbone 0
émission de CO2 à échéance 2030 pour
leur transport public intérieur urbain
c'est la raison pour laquelle elle
débute comme cela mais la plupart de nos
projets sont développés à proximité
d'axes routier permettant demain à des
camions de venir se charger
voilà la différence par rapport à la
partie hydrogène versus la partie
batterie électrique
si je fais
même si tu es arrivé un tout petit peu
plus tard dans votre déroulé de
questions sur la partie train sur la
partie train c'est exactement pareil
aujourd'hui on fait vous avez
400 en fait lignes ou rame de TER qui
devront être renouvelés à échéance 2028
et 400 autres qui devront être
renouvelés à échéance 2030 parmi
celles-ci
vous avez en fait ce que la SNCF appelle
une mission la mission en fait de C TER
elle est double elle est en mode
électrique et en mode
autre chose que l'électricité est
souvent effectivement du fioul ce sont
typiquement des lignes comme Paris
Auxerre Laroche-Migennes ou une partie
en fait est en caténaire et de l'autre
partie en fait est en fioul on va
l'appeler comme ça
demain en fait le train qui est
développé par Alstom qui est un hybride
ou un bimode comme le dit Alstom à
savoir un caténaire avec la partie
électrique et un hydrogène pour la
partie qui devra être substituée donc
par l'hydrogène versus celle qui est
aujourd'hui distribuée par le diesel et
donc ce sont ces
Ramla qui sont demain
à substituer donc et à transformer en
région lisse de manière à pouvoir
effectivement décarboner c'est
locomotive puisque elles sont dans des
dans des villes ou dans des petites
des petites sites urbains et qui
évidemment viennent profondément
carbonées le comment la ville ou le ou
la petite commune donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle là encore nous avons en
miroir ou en perspective de pouvoir
décarboner les les trains en associant
notre équipement déjà existant pour
venir effectivement alimenter en
hydrogène gazeux puisque aujourd'hui en
fait ce sont des piles à combustibles
qui ont été choisis par les fournisseurs
de train et donc de les alimenter par
l'hydrogène électrolytique gazeux que
nous produisons grâce aux électrolyseurs
que nous installons
concernant
la partie
multiplication des électrolyseurs et les
difficultés rencontrées et les
gigafactory aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est que vous avez
l'électrolyse de l'eau c'est pas du tout
inconnu ça fait des années des dizaines
d'années que ça existe
ce qui est toujours dit
différent alors peut-être je faire un
petit aparté technique ou technologique
pardonnez-moi vous avez aujourd'hui deux
types d'électrolyseur vous avez un
électrolyseur basse température et un
électrolyseur haute température dans le
basse température vous avez dessous
famille vous avez l'alcalin et vous avez
Le Pen proton et le changement Bran et
puis vous avez la haute température qui
lui en fait
fonctionne à double sens ce serait je
dire puisque vous utilisez de
l'électricité et de la chaleur je vais
en venir
sur la partie électrolyseur basse
température ce sont les technologies les
plus matures aujourd'hui ce sont des
technologies qui existent depuis je
dirais des années à minima pour
l'alcalin ce qui aujourd'hui rend les
choses un peu plus difficiles ou plus
complexes c'est la capacité à passer de
petites installations d'électrolyseurs
qui aujourd'hui sont dans un container
ses pieds comme vous pouvez voir sur les
camions ces électrolyseurs aujourd'hui 1
2 3 4 mégawatts c'est la capacité à les
faire passer à l'échelle de manière à
pouvoir demain construire des
électrolyseurs qui ne seront plus de 1
en quelques mégawatts mais de plusieurs
dizaines voire centaines de mégawatts
qui sont les puissances du Parlement
électrique pardon qui sont des
puissances requises pour les grandes
installations de nos industriels et
revenir
c'est le passage à l'échelle qui
aujourd'hui déterminante
les gigafactory qui ont on a pu le voir
sur la France faire être bénéficiaire de
plusieurs fabricants d'électrolyseurs
que ça soit l'alcalin avec ma fille que
ça soit la haute température avec johnya
que ça soit le père avec halogène John
Cockerill également sur l'alcalin c'est
une capacité petite à passer à l'échelle
de manière industrielle autrement dit
c'est de pouvoir non plus fabriquer ses
électrolyseurs de manière
artisanale si je puis l'exprimer ainsi
mais de manière plus industrielle ça
c'est le premier point et la capacité à
passer à l'échelle et à faire les
électrolyseurs à produire les élections
liseurs et à le fabriquer de manière
industrielle ça sera également la
capacité à réduire les coûts de
fabrication de ces électrolyseurs
aujourd'hui quand on prend un
électrolyseur la part de l'électrolyseur
dans le coup de revient de l'hydrogène
évidemment ça va dépendre des du prix de
l'électricité bien évidemment mais
aujourd'hui encore un électrolyseur il
est autour de 1,2 à 1,5 millions d'euros
par mégawatt
pour demain être en capacité d'être plus
compétitif et bien il faudra
effectivement pouvoir grâce à la
capacité des fabricants d'électrolyseurs
et gigafactory à réduire au moins de
moitié la fabrique le coût de
fabrication de ces électrolyseurs ça
c'est le premier point
les difficultés que nous pouvons
également ou que les électrolyseurs les
fabricants d'électro rencontrent ce sont
des difficultés de manque de recul
oserais-je dire puisque ces
électrolyseurs de manière industrielle
n'ont pas encore été totalement
fabriquées et donc nous n'avons pas
véritablement de recul sur la
performance de ces électrolyseurs sur la
durabilité de ces électroviseurs
aujourd'hui pour nous par exemple nous
prenons des hypothèses qu'un
électrolyseur va durer 10 ans et puis
qu'il faudra le changer ce qui en soi
n'est pas un problème ça se fait un peu
en Plug and Play oserais-je dire en tout
cas sur les petits de les petits
ouvrages de production que nous avons
mais en tout état de cause ce sont des
hypothèses qui nous faut vérifier et
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
nous avons pris cette participation dans
la société McPhee avec laquelle nous
travaillons à l'accélération de la durée
de vie de l'électrolyseur sur notre
plateforme de test Renardière pour
justement permettre à mieux comprendre
jusque quand l'électrolyseur ou les
stacks les stacks de l'électrolyseur
devront être changés
donc on voit bien que les gigas Factory
vont permettre petites de produire
massivement raison pour laquelle on voit
des giga Factory qui sont capables de
sortir entre 1 et 3 gigawatts par an
de pouvoir les produire de manière très
industrielle non plus rapidement
et puis enfin de pouvoir effectivement
être en capacité d'avoir le recul
nécessaire sur la fabrication sur la
performance et la durabilité de ces de
ces électrolyseurs ensuite
vous me parliez de la partie
sécurité et sûreté aujourd'hui les
électrolyseurs tels que nous les
installons aujourd'hui sont des
électrolyseurs dans un container lequel
et qualifié de zone atex c'est-à-dire
vous avez des équipements à l'intérieur
en fait qui sont fabriqués de telle
manière que ils puissent effectivement
prévoir ou éviter tout risque des
explosion eu égard au fait d'avoir
effectivement un certain nombre autre
que capteurs installés qui permettent
effectivement de détecter ces
risques là donc je dirais que la
aujourd'hui le risque sécurité et
maîtrisé ne serait-ce que parce que il
est
circonscrit ce qui fait que les les
électrolyseurs et aujourd'hui
l'hydrogène et quelque chose de
particulièrement connu par les grands
groupes comme les gaziers industriels
qui maîtrisent parfaitement en fait ces
conditions-là et d'ailleurs le
le la filière s'est organisée en la
matière autour de France hydrogène qui a
mis en place des groupes de travail dans
ce cadre-là et qui travaille notamment à
l'élaboration des normes dans dans le
cadre de ces extruiseurs petits ouvrages
ou gros ouvrages et de notre côté par
exemple nous avons effectivement créé un
mis en place un partenariat avec
inhérissent de manière à être je dirais
le plus à jour possible sur les
meilleures conditions d'exploitation de
ces électrolyseurs en milieu urbain ou
en milieu rural
pardon pardonnez-moi je réponds juste à
une dernière question monsieur le
Président qui de monsieur le rapporteur
concernant les projets en retard
alors effectivement
de notre côté nous avions
donc nous avons
plusieurs types de guichets oserais-je
dire qui nous permettent puisque on l'a
bien compris l'hydrogène électrolytique
nécessite encore le soutien public
le soutien public qui a été aujourd'hui
mis en oeuvre et décidé a été
décidé d'être sur la partie
investissement c'est la raison pour
laquelle pour nos projets de mobilité
nous avons la chance d'avoir ces appels
approchés territoriaux de l'ADEME qui
permet effectivement de pouvoir aider à
mettre en place ces petits ouvrages qui
ont vocation a grossir et qui sont
effectivement des aides des aides au
CAPEX afin de déployer des installations
je dirais à proximité des usages parce
que c'est là aussi très important il
s'agit d'abord de produire là où ça
consomme
pour ces appels à projets et bien on
peut se réjouir qu'ils existent on peut
se réjouir qu'il y en a eu plusieurs on
pourrait se réjouir que le délai
d'instruction
aille plus vite dans l'obtention
effectivement de la signature des
conventions de financement
concernant les projets industriels pour
lesquels souvent bon nombre d'entre eux
ont fait l'objet de demande
d'investissement ou de demandes de
subvention par le biais des six PCI donc
les fameux imperton programming trust
qui passe évidemment du fait d'un
déplammement des aides d'État par une
instruction près de la DG comp et
aujourd'hui ce qu'on constate c'est que
il y a une forme de goulot
d'étranglement par l'équipe européenne
qui font que pour nos projets
nous devions avoir des réponses sur
notre projet boréalisme notre projet
domo sur notre projet inovie depuis plus
de six mois
et aujourd'hui nous sommes aujourd'hui
malheureusement suspendu en l'air
oserait-je dire puisque ces projets qui
ont été pré-notifiés
sont encore en cours d'instruction sur
la notification ce qui évidemment va
entraîner des délais dans la mise en
oeuvre de certaines de nos décisions
d'investissement parce que avant d'être
notifié et un certain nombre d'études à
effectuer et nous comme nos partenaires
investisseurs pouvant être parfois un
peu plus prudent quant à la dépense
étant donné que nous n'avons pas la
certitude que le projet sera notifié en
temps et heure
ux
bonjour madame vous parliez de vos
projets d'investissement est-ce que vous
pouvez me dire un petit mot du projet
belle étoile à Saint-Fons qui est un
gros projet je crois que c'est 85 MW au
niveau de l'électrolyseur et puis nous
dire si vous tenez le le comment dire
non pas le calendrier devant le
calendrier mais est-ce que vous tenez
également le montant d'investissement
prévisionnel de 100 millions
donc effectivement le projet que nous
avons à belle étoile avec notre
partenaire de mots-cémicals est un
projet extrêmement ambitieux puisqu'il
vise à substituer l'hydrogène gris en
totalité par de l'hydrogène
électrolytique ce qui n'est pas le cas
des autres
donc c'est en ce sens très ambitieux de
fait évidemment il faut penser que
substituer un hydrogène grippe en
hydrogène vert ou bas carbone va
nécessiter une forme je dirais de de
préparation afin que le site ne se
retrouve pas sans oxygène hydrogène au
moment il faudra évidemment qui produit
son érogène pour fabriquer ses produits
finaux donc c'est 85 mégawatts
effectivement qui dont le projet en fait
a été là comme je le disais à l'instant
pré notifié dans le cadre en fait des
aides d'État et PCI et qui aujourd'hui
en fait est reste encore en suspens
u égard à la difficulté de la DG contre
en fait d'instruire ce projet là
si
d'ici
quelques mois nous n'avons pas de retour
sur
la notification de ce projet
ça met en péril le planning tel que deux
moqueries
dans le cas de sa propre opérationnalité
c'est à dire c'est contraintes
d'opération ces contraintes
d'exploitation de son propre site d'où
l'impératiful
l'impératif de
faire accélérer
auprès de nos amis européens de la
Commission européenne tous ces
l'instruction de ces projets qui ont
déjà été cotés France par l'ADEME par la
DGE pré-instruit et où on est
effectivement en attente de la petite
équipe de DG si j'ai bien tout compris
simplement quand vous dites accéléré au
niveau européen qui peut accélérer et
bien écoutez monsieur président
aujourd'hui
je crois comprendre que Monsieur le
Ministre Lescure et ses équipes madame
la ministre panière une hachée
beaucoup
ce domaine vous voudrez-je dire pour
pouvoir faire accélérer
les instructions
des solutions semblent être recherchées
ne connaissons pas la totalité
évidemment une fine mais en tout état de
cause
faire instruire le dossier soit par une
autre équipe soit en d'autant les
équipes de légers qu'on peut être en
préemptant certains sujets côté France
parce qu'il y a un petit peu plus de
ressources j'avoue que aujourd'hui les
solutions ne se présentent pas de
manière aussi
que nous le souhaiterions
plusieurs questions Madame la Directrice
Générale d'abord tout à l'heure vous
avez abordé la captation CO2
notamment sortie cimenterie j'ai noté
tout ça pour produire du methanol
quelle degré de maturité il y a sur ce
type de technique
est-ce que vous voyez un potentiel
important quels sont les obstacles et
est-ce que ça peut du coup doper si
j'ose dire la production et la
décarbonation comment vous voyez cette
technique là c'est parfois il y a des
controverses quand même il y a des
questionnements sur l'aérien tout à
l'heure vous avez abordé la question
semble-t-il en disant que ou alors j'ai
mal noté mais que vous étiez prêt à
produire des carburants de synthèse
est-ce que j'ai bien compris si oui quel
est le degré de discussion qu'on peut
avoir avec des compagnies parfois on
entend dire que les compagnies vont se
fournir à l'étranger
est-ce que ça marche est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à répondre à un besoin est-ce
que vous avez estimé ce besoin
ça paraît aussi une question importante
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure vous disiez
qu'il fallait dépasser le clivage sur
les couleurs de l'hydrogène enfin c'est
cette question de savoir quelle était
l'origine de l'électricité semble-t-il
de pas je résume pas tout là-dedans dans
cette formule là mais est-ce que vous
pouvez approfondir un peu cette
cette question et puis
bon je reviendrai peut-être après mais
je vais vous laisser répondre à ces
premières questions
oui alors effectivement
concernant la capture de CO2 aujourd'hui
il y a comme je disais tout à l'heure
des endroits où on ne saura pas les
carbonées autrement que par la capture
de CO2 qui sont donc notamment les les
usines de cimenterie raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui nous travaillons
avec ces usines cimenteries en France
alors soit pour fabriquer du methanol on
la combinaison en fait de CO2 plus H2
directement par une colonne de
méthanisation en fait permet de
fabriquer du méthanol qui aujourd'hui en
fait directement utiliser et utilisable
par des gros bateaux puisque aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'armateurs ont déjà en fait
commander
il y en a certains qui ont déjà en fait
des bateaux à méthanol qui existent déjà
à Marc a déjà des bateaux il en assise
qui circulent déjà au méthanol et je
crois que le groupe CMA-CGM a également
annoncé une première commande de six
bateaux puis une deuxième commande de
ciseaux à venir prochainement donc c'est
bateau à méthanol vont fonctionner il
faut rappeler également que la molécule
méthanol c'est une molécule de base en
termes de Chimie il y a quelques temps
d'ailleurs le méthanol était produit en
France aujourd'hui il est produit dans
des contrées un peu exotiques qu'on fait
de manière je dirais peu propre puisque
c'est à base de méthane et qui est
importée là où on en a besoin évidemment
on peut on peut regretter là encore
l'action je dirais la carbonation
puisque il faut transporter ce méthanol
donc aujourd'hui on est en capacité de
capturer effectivement ce CO2 sur les
sites cimenteries
ce que
on peut dire c'est que la capture de CO2
les techniques les technologies elles
existent
on a des grands industriels français
avec lesquels nous travaillons qui
s'affairent il y a plusieurs
technologies nous sommes nous en train
de voir quelle est la meilleure
technologie vous avez été technologies
amies etc
mais vous avez voilà des grands groupes
comme Air Liquide qui savent en fait
faire cette capture de CO2 de manière
industrielle
ce qui est important à savoir c'est que
évidemment pour répondre à votre
question c'est que ça peut bien
évidemment doper la production enfin
d'abord la décarbonation d'une part
puisque tous ces senti en fait eux n'ont
pas besoin d'hydrogène pour leur
production finale mais par contre ils
ont besoin des carbonées et ils ne
savent pas électrifier directement par
contre ils ont du CO2 dans leur fumée
donc c'est une manière effectivement
d'accélérer la production d'une part de
décarbonée par la capture de CO2 et
d'autre part de produire effectivement
d'autres molécules que sont ses dérivés
de l'âge 2 ou c'est carburants de
synthèse lesquels sont soit fabriqués à
partir donc d'une usine de métallisation
qui est juste à côté de l'électrolyseur
soit à partir d'une autre technologie et
ça ça va fabriquer du méthanol pour les
bateaux soit à partir en fait d'une
technologie allemande bien connue qui
s'appelle le Fisher truck et qui là va
produire en fait ce qu'on appelle les
safs les substénébreux et qui
effectivement sont une autre une autre
technologie une autre je dirais réaction
chimique et qui est effectuée nous
travaillons sur ces deux types de
projets 1 dans la région donc de
Montalieu avec le cimentier Vicat et un
autre dont la région de Saint-Nazaire
avec un autre cimentier pour produire
effectivement des des safs pour lesquels
des ofters comme on a l'habitude de dire
c'est à dire des clients industriels ont
déjà formulé leur première main
intention que ça soit des gens comme
des fabricants d'avions ou des
fabricants de S ou des opérateurs
d'avion donc il y a déjà une
très ferme intention
de ces opérateurs de ses acteurs
d'acheter effectivement ce type de
carburant
donc oui ça répond à votre première
question ça s'adopte la décarbonation et
ça aide à
la commande ces industriels qui peuvent
ne pas avoir d'autres possibilités là où
il est important ce que je disais tout à
l'heure dans le propos liminaire à
savoir attention il s'agit pour nous de
bien faire la différence et de bien
valoriser aussi le CO2 fatal parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est parti pour à
l'origine uniquement le CO2 biogénique
si je fais un cours
courte réduction ou un raccourci le CO2
biogénique et celui qui où on brûle en
fait des matières
recyclable si je pile d'exprimer ainsi
mais on brûle d'autres matières dans les
sites cimenteries et il ne faut pas
négliger qu'une partie de ce CO2 et bien
il doit être capturé et dans ce cadre-là
il est serré souhaitable de pouvoir un
minima soit reconnaître ce CO2 fatal ou
si on y arrive pas à pouvoir privilégier
favoriser ce CO2 fatal dans les
enfouissement géologiques de manière à
pouvoir le faire évacuer là où on a
encore les cavités salées en question
nous travaillons nous en tout cas sur la
capture de CO2 tel que la réglementation
aujourd'hui nous permet d'être plus
optimiste et plus performant sur la
capture de CO2 biogénique si on sur nos
projets avec nos sites SIM entiers
partenaires
et donc je réponds aussi à votre
deuxième question sur l'aérien oui
ces carburant de synthèse nous sommes en
capacité d'en faire les technologies les
briques technologiques indiquent prises
individuellement elles existent ce qui
évidemment fait je dirais la
substantifique moelle de tout ça c'est
l'intégration de l'ensemble de ces
briques technologiques et c'est la
raison pour laquelle des grands groupes
industriels sont en capacité de le faire
soit des groupes comme EDF ou des gens
avec lesquels nous travaillons en
partenariat qui sont des gens qui sont
capables en fait de faire l'intégration
de ces différentes briques je pense
notamment à des grands groupes comme
techniques
les couleurs de la 2 effectivement à
dépassé
alors j'ai envie de dire le débat sur
toutes les couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel
toujours du loin derrière nous et
heureusement
néanmoins on voit bien
que la France a parfois un petit peu du
mal à se faire entendre au niveau de
l'Europe de par sa spécificité d'un mix
énergétique où électrique bacarbonne et
avec les centrales nucléaires ou
hydroélectriques pour ne pas les citer
ce qui est ce qui évidemment bien
dommage ne serait-ce que parce que et
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure
monsieur le Président pour le coup on a
nous la capacité de voir les deux côtés
du Rhin oser puisque nous avons une
filiale en France c'est une filiale en
Allemagne
en Allemagne on a évidemment pas
d'autres choix que d'aller
contractualiser en fait ce qu'on appelle
des powerpachez agreement donc des
contrats d'achat d'électricité
renouvelable tout simplement parce que
aller chercher de l'électricité du grid
enfin du réseau électrique allemand
serait bien plus dommage à blanc que que
de prendre de l'électricité renouvelable
il est extrêmement
carboné on a d'ailleurs on avait
d'ailleurs fait une petite étude un
moment donné on avait calculé le comment
le
les tonnes de CO2 éviter sur un véhicule
hydrogène à partir de l'électricité mix
allemand ou à partir de l'électricité
mix France ou renouvelable
en fait il vaut mieux avoir de
l'hydrogène produit par vaporéformage
plus de gris plutôt que d'avoir de
l'hydrogène produit à partir d'un mix
allemand aussi carboné
qu'il est donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on sait exactement les
difficultés que l'on rencontre quand on
doit en fait un contractualiser sur un
contrat d'achat d'électricité totalement
renouvelable pour la simple et bonne
raison que le contrat d'achat
d'électricité renouvelable et bien par
essence même il est intermittent mais
quand vous parlez à un industriel un
industriel lui il peut pas s'arrêter
comme ça sa production
ou son alimentation d'hydrogène donc
souvent on a besoin en fait de
surdimensionner le contrat d'achat
d'électricité
surdimensionner l'électrolyseur voir
surdimensionner le stockage ce qui est
une phiné appelle c'est
surdimensionnements à des augmentations
de coûts d'investissement évidemment que
l'on sait éviter en France tout j'ai
envie de dire
le premier de combat que l'on a réussi à
obtenir dans le cadre en fait des textes
réglementaires donc des actes délégués
qui sont le fait de pouvoir nous
affranchir en Allemagne d'avoir en fait
à
boire ce qu'on appelle l'additionnalité
c'est à dire de construire des parcs
renouvelables additionnels pour pouvoir
alimenter les électrolyseurs en
électricité
renouvelable on peut effectivement le
faire avec avec le mix énergétique et je
crois que c'est très important que la
France en a parfaitement conscience on
est assez isolés évidemment la
spécificité française sur le mec
énergétique est tellement tellement
vous proposerai-je dire que il est peu
ou pas extrêmement audible mais en tout
cas c'est un combat qu'il faut qu'il
faut mener longuement durablement
ardemment parce que c'est ce qui fait
effectivement que nous aurons d'une part
cette capacité à fournir en continu nos
électrolyseurs pour l'alimentation en
continu de nos industriels et puis
pourquoi pas demain grâce à une
électricité à partir d'un mix
énergétique
encore plus important avec le programme
nucléaire et bien pourquoi pas importer
ou plus exactement exporté notre
hydrogène vers l'Allemagne plutôt que
l'Allemagne aille importer de
l'hydrogène fabriquée dans des contrées
exotiques ou on risque encore d'avoir
des problèmes de souveraineté
énergétique qui ne sont ni plus ni moins
déplacées vers l'hydrogène
et revenir sur le CO2 fatal
à vous entendre on a l'impression que
réutiliser CO2 fatal il y a des
réticences où il y a quelles sont elles
ou des difficultés et puis dans des
auditions au niveau des électrolyseurs
on
on a entendu qu'on pourrait devenir
exportateur l'électrocuteur donc moi je
voudrais savoir si ça vous paraît
plausible et puis dans ce domaine-là qui
quelles sont nos concurrents
alors je vais commencer par la deuxième
[Musique]
la deuxième question monsieur président
ou plus avec vous apportez la réponse à
la deuxième question aujourd'hui nous
avons la chance effectivement d'avoir
des fabricants d'électrolyseurs lesquels
sont promus par l'état français pour
pouvoir produire
des électrolyseurs
lesquels peuvent être tout à fait
exportables je pense qu'il faut être
extrêmement vigilant
sur alors pardon ces électrolyseurs il y
en a évidemment en France il y a pas
beaucoup de fabricants un électrolyseur
en Europe et on a en Allemagne alors en
Allemagne on peut citer pour les crusard
alcalin à pression atmosphérique comme
tuffton crew Siemens qui lui est sur la
technologie PM
et puis vous avez également Sunfire sur
la technologie haute température après
vous avez
le Norvégien Nell et puis vous avez
l'anglais ITM en France on a quand même
la chance d'avoir même si aujourd'hui on
est sur des maturités peut-être pas
aussi élevées et les industriels sont en
train de de faire tout pour accélérer
quand même ma fille nous avons et le
gène nous avons
genevia et nous avons
j'ai oublié pardonnez-moi et le gène max
fille genevia
et John Cockerill dont l'usine
d'assemblage va se situer merci Arthur
va se situer à Spar en Alsace là où il
faut absolument être vigilant c'est
comme je disais tout à l'heure les giga
Factory doivent permettre
l'industrialisation la mise massive sur
le marché la production en mode
je dirais le passage un peu
de de fabrication de l'automobile à la
chaîne versus celle qui se faisait
auparavant c'est exactement le même
enjeu c'est de pouvoir effectivement
faire de manière moins artisanale des
gestes en fait qui sont aujourd'hui fait
par des par des personnes demain doivent
être faits par des robots
et puis il restera toujours évidemment
une capacité à pouvoir à devoir faire
des gestes par l'homme
ensuite
là où il faut de mon point de vue être
très vigilant et je pense que
les leçons que nous avons pu tirer de la
concurrence chinoise sur le soleil doit
nous permettre effectivement d'être plus
précautionneux et plus prudent quand à
l'arrivée des électroviseurs Chinois les
électrolyseurs chinois ils existent
ils le font de manière massive il
produisent massivement ils ont un marché
qui leur permet en fait de le faire
sans problème aujourd'hui sont
circonscrit sur leur propre marché on a
la chance d'avoir des gens qui ont des
électrolyseurs qui n'ont pas les
performances telles que nous souhaitons
nous les avoir en Europe et aussi parce
que
ça implique derrière la capacité de
faire des ouvrages des électroviseurs je
dirais sur une empreinte au sol plus
petite donc d'avoir en fait une capacité
à faire plus
avec moins de stacks si on peut le
qualifier ainsi le stack étant en fait
le cœur du réacteur donc les Chinois
pourraient tout à fait demain venir
vendre leurs électrolyseurs nous obstant
le fait que nous avons quand même
quelques arguments qui sont des
arguments de performance des arguments
de qualité
et puis les leçons du solaire dit il y a
quelques années
merci monsieur le Président question sur
un point que vous avez abordé de manière
un peu cursive la stratégie allemande
alors vous avez abordé une part de
l'expérience que vous avez vous-même
là-bas et des projets que vous y
développez mais on entend que
l'Allemagne est plutôt sur une stratégie
d'importation
alors si on la compare la stratégie
française qu'est ce que ça vous
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire premier
élément deuxièmement là on voit bien
qu'il y a des appels à projets pour le
lancement de
d'un réseau de
production d'hydrogène et puis parfois
on entend l'idée de système de tâches de
léopard avec
potentiellement
un réseau de transport qui sera connecté
est-ce que ça a du sens comment vous
voyez ce déploiement là parce que c'est
la bonne méthode est-ce qu'il faudrait
procéder différemment
et puis puisque je suis sur le transport
d'hydrogène il y a cette idée de
d'un système justement qui viendrait du
sud de l'Europe
voire depuis l'Afrique du Nord qui irait
jusqu'à l'Allemagne qu'est-ce que ça
vous inspire est-ce que là aussi vous
avez une appréciation positive sur tout
ça est-ce que c'est c'est la bonne
option
monsieur
tout à l'heure
voilà le CO2 le CO2
donc effectivement ce que vous ce qu'il
faut avoir en tête c'est que dans l'ocre
dans le cadre de l'acte délégué red 2
donc qui sont donc qui datent qui ont
été je dirais avalisés en février de
cette année
on ne n'est pas considéré le CO2
industriel après 2041
de la même façon qu'il n'y a pas de
distinction de CO2 industriel et fatal
et c'est en ce sens que je dis attention
parce que ça va donner un avantage
je dirais du CO2 dit biogénique alors
que le CO des fatales peut-être capturé
et procéder aux objectifs que la France
dont la France est dotée pour la
décarbonation et ses objectifs de
décarbonation c'est pour ça que c'est
très important de tenir compte de ces
CO2 fatal
pour revenir sur le sujet
2041 ça paraît loin mais ce sont des
investissements qui s'amortissent sur
des durées longues aussi bien du côté
des producteurs que du côté des
industriels qui changent leur process
donc on a des industriels qui sont très
inquiets de cette de cette disposition
là
qui donc figure dans le dans
la révision de la directive sur les
carburants renouvelables donc si ces
carburants ne sont plus considérés comme
vers à partir de 2040
le mode opératoire industriel il perd de
sa valeur et donc c'est très préoccupant
décision d'investissement ne seront pas
prises effectivement
pour revenir monsieur le rapporteur si
vous vous sur vos questions
la question des imports et des exports
évidemment
l'Allemagne aujourd'hui fait face à un
énorme problème dans sa transition
énergétique qui est que
elle ne va pas pouvoir tapisser son sol
de chancelet ou chants éolien modulo
évidemment tout ce qui va se passer dans
le dans la mer du Nord
d'une part et que aujourd'hui bon nombre
des équipements renouvelables sont
dans le Nord avec une grosse partie des
consommations qui sont dans le sud
l'Allemagne est un pays gazier et donc
évidemment à défaut de je dirais comme
nous d'être un pays électrique
comme tout pays elle va s'appuyer sur
ses assets tangibles ces actifs
tangibles c'est la raison pour laquelle
elle prévoit à juste titre selon sa
propre stratégie et ses propres actifs
tout simplement de pouvoir utiliser les
actifs dont elle dispose à savoir soit
le
l'éolien en mer du Nord soit de pouvoir
utiliser des réseaux de transport de gaz
à transformer parce que la molécule
hydrogène ne peut pas être transportée
dans les réseaux de gaz aujourd'hui tels
qui sont elle est trop petite et c'est
ces réseaux seront
pas assez étanche à la transporter toute
seule et c'est la raison pour laquelle
ils ont ils envisagent d'utiliser donc
ces réseaux de transport de gaz de les
rétrocité pour pouvoir transporter la
molécule hydrogène
mais même ça ça ne pourra pas en fait
servir à des carboner leur site
industriel et c'est la raison pour
laquelle afin d'avoir un accès à une
électricité réputée
peu cher que peuvent être du soleil
en Amérique et bien ils envisagent
effectivement de pouvoir transporter de
pouvoir fabriquer à partir de solaire ou
d'éolien en Afrique pardon du Nord par
exemple et de pouvoir effectivement
transformer cette hydrogène
soit en hydrogène liquide
soit en ammoniac soit en méthanol pour
pouvoir le faire transporter plus
facilement en Allemagne ce qu'il faut
quand même avoir en tête c'est que un
producteur de renouvelable
quand il construit un parc pourquoi
devrait-il vendre une électricité peu
chère
à un fabricant ou un demandeur
d'hydrogène alors que il pourrait
prétendre le ventre bien plus cher sur
le marché
première question la deuxième des
questions c'est
imaginons encore qu'il puisse envisager
parce que il a un contrat long terme qui
peut arranger son investissement
que ce dernier
donc vendent son électricité un
acheteur d'hydrogène
pour transporter l'hydrogène aujourd'hui
elle ne peut pas se transporter de
manière gazeuse il faudrait il y a pas
de temps pour ça si vous voulez il faut
pouvoir le transformer ou en hydrogène
liquide le transformer en hydrogène
liquide nécessite des investissements
additionnels pour pouvoir passer du gaz
au liquide au delà des investissements
additionnels donc c'est de l'argent au
delà d'investissement additionnel c'est
également
de l'énergie parce que pour transformer
une molécule gaz en liquide il faut de
l'énergie
et tout ça dans un contexte où on doit
parler de d'hydrogène gazeux versus
liquide de manière massive on n'est pas
sur les quelques kilos pardonnez-moi
quelques kilos quelques centaines de
kilos que l'on fait quand on fait
décoller une fusée on parle de beaucoup
beaucoup plus d'hydrogène liquides donc
la question là aussi c'est la question
du rendement parce que une fois que l'on
a transporté transformé l'hydrogène
gazeux en hydrogène liquide qu'on l'a
mis dans des tanks pour pouvoir le
transformer le transporter vers
l'Allemagne
liquide qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
vous le retransformer en ammoniac il
faut le retransformer en hydrogène
gazeux donc pardonnez-moi à l'expression
un peu familière rebelote il faut
rechanger
cette hydrogène ça nécessite des CAPEX
et ça nécessite de l'électricité
et c'est la même chose pour la moniac
sauf évidemment à ce que l'on puisse
considérer que l'on utilise dans ces
cas-là l'ammoniac directement pour de la
molécule ammoniac et non pas de la
renommée derrière mais là dans ces cas
là on va parler de souveraineté
industrielle de souveraineté de
l'ammoniac
en Europe versus de l'ammoniac produit
dans des contrées où nous pourrions ne
pas avoir complètement la main sur la
stabilité géopolitique de cette
fabrication
c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous estimons nous absolument important
de privilégier la production d'hydrogène
ou d'ammoniac en Europe et pour
l'ammoniac c'est extrêmement important
puisque
il s'en va derrière de la souveraineté
de notre agriculture et une fine et de
l'alimentation
donc c'est extrêmement important que
d'avoir
je dirais toute cette chaîne de valeur
et de ce qu'elle implique ton énergie
que en montant d'investissement inhérent
quand otage léopard monsieur le
rapporteur
le réseau de transport en Europe il
existera à l'instar que le réseau
d'électricité a existé quand on passe
production on pense forcément évacuation
de l'électricité on pense forcément
évacuation de l'hydrogène pour pouvoir
effectivement le le
je dirais le transporter de manière
massive
nous on dit pas dans le groupe EDF qu'il
n'y aura pas de transport d'hydrogène
par hydrogénétique on dit simplement que
la temporalité n'est pas la même avant
de transporter faut déjà commencer par
produire
et pour produire il faut qu'on ait des
clients
et les clients aujourd'hui ils ont
besoin d'avoir un hydrogène à côté de
chez eux ce sont nos industriels et pour
que nos industriels restent sur les
territoires français pour que notre
industriels ils continuent à produire
les produits finis qui produisent
aujourd'hui et bien il faut produire de
l'hydrogène juste à côté de leur site
industriel
une fois qu'on aura ces productions
massives rien nous empêche de faire
grossir ses installations d'une part et
où je dirais de dévoyer pardonnez-moi
une partie de cette production pour
ensuite l'alimenter sur un réseau
distribution lequel sera alimenté par un
réseau de transport pour pouvoir
effectivement évacuer massivement
l'hydrogène produit mais commençons déjà
par produire localement
à destination de nos industriels de nos
clients afin que ces derniers puissent
effectivement des carboner leur propre
site et la distribution puis le
transport de l'hydrogène se fera mais la
temporalité n'est pas la même
oui volontiers monsieur le Président
d'abord tout à l'heure vous avez abordé
la question de la stabilisation du
cadrage réglementaire et des
financements publics alors je voudrais
juste que on puisse tirer
profit réellement de vos observations
vous inviter peut-être à les repréciser
si ça vous dérange pas pour que on voit
qu'est-ce que vous mettez derrière ces
deux formules là stabilisation du cadre
réglementaire et sur les financements
publics vous l'avez reparti abordé mais
je voudrais quand même que vous y
revenir si vous êtes d'accord d'autant
que vous avez abordé la problématique de
l'IRA américain
et
ma question sera simple c'est qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de la réponse européenne
là-dessus et puis de manière très
pratique puisque dans cette mission
d'information visage c'est à faire des
propositions essayer de voir comment on
peut éventuellement soutenir la filière
quels sont là de ce point de vue les
beaux attentes particulières
pour la réponse à l'IRA américain voilà
deux questions d'abord
alors effectivement
par rapport à l'IRA effectivement
américain
et par rapport à aux mécanisme de
soutien à la à la production
alors ce qu'il faut enfin je rappelle
les 6,5 gigawatts d'électrolyse installé
en 2030 avec une enveloppe budgétaire de
9 milliards d'euros sur 10 ans
les mécanismes de soutien à la
production à la production donc ces 4
milliards sur les 9 milliards
donc de la stratégie H2 avec un soutien
d'abord aux OPEX puis d'abord au CAPEX
puis aux OPEX on est toujours en un
temps de cette ordonnance qui est qui a
été mise en oeuvre et qui devrait avoir
lieu prochainement sur l'appel d'Abel
d'appel d'offres sur la base du meilleur
ratio de l'euro de tonnes de CO2 et
éviter
cette première monture du mécanisme a
été présentée fin 2022 et prévoyait le
financement de 1 gigawatt d'électrolyse
d'ici 2027
150 en 2024 250 ans 2025 300 2026 puis
300 en 2027 cette notification est
toujours en cours
auprès de la Commission européenne
ensuite nous avons le sujet de la de la
thyruertin qui est cet axe incitative à
l'utilisation donc d'énergie
renouvelable dans les transports alors
si nous on aime beaucoup en fait ce
mécanisme qui est très efficace et
structurant pour le modèle d'affaires
des projets hydrogène à destination de
la mobilité parce que combiner avec de
l'aide aux OPEX il permet vraiment de
réduire l'écart de compétitivité avec le
diesel c'est vraiment très important ce
qu'on pourrait souhaiter alors des
discussions vont pouvoir avoir lieu mais
une amélioration qu'on pourrait
souhaiter finalement c'est d'avoir un
une application d'un multiplicateur de
deux à l'hydrogène bacarbone bas carbone
à l'image de ce qui est fait pour le
renouvelable finalement et à intensité
carbone équivalente de manière à étendre
le périmètre également au maritime
puisque les carbus réacteurs aériens
sont déjà sont déjà inclus et par
exemple si vous parliez tout à l'heure
monsieur
typiquement au UK
vous avez 10 GW de capacité de
production d'âge de donc programmé en
2030 donc au moins 50% par électrolyse
c'est un milliard de financements
publics budgétique d'ici 2025
et
les Britanniques et peut-être avec une
définition pragmatique de l'hydrogène
qui est basée sur son contenu carbone
et non l'origine de l'électricité
utilisée ce qui s'appelle le low carbone
à Legends standard
et les premiers appels d'offres de
soutien au CAPEX et aux OPEX ont été
lancés alors même que le UK avait
singulièrement du retard et bien ils
sont en train en fait de
rattraper ce retard alors même que la
France était très en avance aux
USA effectivement la publication de
l'IRA donc en août 2022 qui comprend un
crédit d'impôt qui peut aller quand même
jusqu'à trois dollars par kilogramme
d'âge 2 sur 10 ans pour les dogène en
dessous d'un certain seuil le seuil
étant de 0,45 kg de CO2 par kg d'âge 2
et donc avec une construction débutant
avant 2033 oui effectivement c'est ces
pays-là
à mettre en perspective des évolutions
et une accélération de l'hydrogène et on
voit d'ores et déjà tout à l'heure je
vous parlais de fabricant
d'électrolyseurs européens mais on voit
aujourd'hui des fabricants
d'électrolyseurs américains dont les
technologies sont éprouvées à qui de
fait pourrait être
bien plus avancé parce qu'ils vont être
amenés à mettre en œuvre des projets
bien plus rapidement que les nôtres en
Europe et donc être plus avancé dans la
mise en oeuvre de leur fabrication même
puisque ils auront plus de commandes
plus de retours d'expérience sur les 10
commande puisque ils auront plus
d'électrolyseurs en exploitation que nos
nos fabricants européens donc oui
effectivement il faut avoir en tête que
ça peut singulièrement jouer sur la
compétitivité de nos de nos fabricants
d'électrolyseurs
ce que j'ai répondu à votre question
monsieur peut-être pas assez
Arthur va compléter
sur le cadre réglementaire donc
effectivement Christelle vous a décrit
un peu les mécanismes de financement
qu'on attend encore donc effectivement
ça c'est aussi une première raison de
que peut prendre les retards dans le
développement des projets au niveau de
la filière mais il y a également un
sujet qui est réglementaire parce que le
surcoût entre les carburants utilisés
typiquement le maritime ou l'aérien et
ce qu'on pourra proposer en matière
d'hydrogène électroétique ou carburant
de synthèse il sera durable donc on a
besoin à la fois des mécanismes de
financement et à la fois des obligations
réglementaires donc qui s'appliquent à
ces secteurs là et il faut que ces
applications réglementaires elles soient
compatibles avec le type de production
qu'on pourrait avoir en France et donc
notamment l'hydrogène et les carburants
de synthèse bas carbone donc aujourd'hui
il y a des avancées qui ont pris
beaucoup de temps et que notamment les
textes fit for fifty-five qui commence à
dont les négociations commencent à
aboutir sur le maritime on arrive à
faire reconnaître les carburantes
synthèse bas carbone pour atteindre les
cibles sur l'aéronautique on n'y est pas
encore
et c'est un point qui est très bloquant
aujourd'hui entre les États membres et
donc effectivement c'est quelque chose
qui bloque parce que comme la comme la
bien dit Christelle pour développer un
projet il faut des clients et ses
clients-là ils attendent de savoir
quelles obligations réglementaires vont
leur incomber pour ensuite avancer avec
les développeurs de projets et donc là
le sort de l'hydrogène et ses dérivés
bas carbone n'est pas encore scellé au
niveau européen et c'est la raison pour
laquelle par rapport à d'autres pays
donc Christelle l'a rappelé
effectivement au Royaume-Uni où on a un
mix électrique qui se rapproche un peu
plus d'une autre par opposition à nos
voisins européens où ils ont établi une
définition très pragmatique ou
l'hydrogène qui sera soutenue public
publiquement et qui pourra contribuer
aux objectifs c'est l'hydrogène qui est
en dessous d'un certain seuil carbone
point et ça permet voilà de développer
de tout ça découle les mécanismes de
soutien et des financements des premiers
projets
voilà pour préciser peut-être un peu ce
qu'on entend par cadre réglementaire
tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué
l'incitation que pourrait représenter
des des contrats d'achat à prix garantie
pour structurer la filière
et dans ce domaine qu'est-ce que vous
entendez vous attendez de l'État
si on fait référence à ce qui s'est
passé pour les énergies ou les filières
renouvelables
alors je vais répondre partiellement et
peut-être laisser ensuite la parole à
Bertrand
[Musique]
quand comme je vous l'ai dit
nous qu'on PDF nous investissons dans
des ouvrages de production et de
commercialisation d'hydrogène
ces investissements sont ces
investissements d'industriels donc à
long terme
en face nous avons des clients qui sont
soit des collectivités soit des
industriels
des amateurs de bateaux soit des
industriels type comme on ne mentionné
tout à l'heure d'homo kimikals on
réalise mais d'autres
ces industriels pour prendre des
décisions d'investissement comme nous
ont besoin de visibilité
ils sont prêts à contractualiser sur sur
de long terme en tout état de cause
aujourd'hui les collectivités
contractualisent des achats d'hydrogène
des chats sur de long terme nos premiers
contrats vont de 9 ans à 20 ans
pour pouvoir effectivement être en
capacité de garantir un prix d'hydrogène
avoir un contrat d'électricité long
terme
et bienvenu
les discussions qui sont en cours
devraient nous permettre de pouvoir
effectivement nous aider nous acheteurs
d'électricité à pouvoir contractualiser
des contrats d'électricité long terme ce
qui devra nous permettre de donner de la
visibilité sur nos contrats de vente
d'hydrogène et donc à nos acheteurs
clients de pouvoir effectivement prendre
les décisions d'investissement parce que
souvent quand on installe un
électrolyseur chez l'industriel on n'est
pas uniquement à faire l'électrolyseur
il y a toute une partie investissement à
prendre en considération par
l'industriel lui-même
et ça il le prend à condition évidemment
de pouvoir avoir la visibilité qui lui
permet de pouvoir rentabiliser ses
investissements
la collectivité a le droit de s'engager
sur 20 ans dans un contrat c'est à dire
sur plus de 3 mandats municipaux en tout
cas ce sont des contrats qui sont dans
le cadre de d'appel d'offres et qui sont
alors pour ce que je vous raconte ce
sont plutôt les syndicats
plutôt que les collectivités
merci Monsieur bridant nous avons
auditionné un certain nombre
d'industriels et éventuellement de
porteurs d'ailleurs de projets
d'électrolyseur mais pas seulement et
chaque fois il y a un point qui revient
en qui concerne d'être plus le groupe
que tu as une amix qui est la question
du délai de raccordement au réseau
est-ce que vous en avez conscience
j'imagine que vous devez entendre ce
point là alors il y a forcément des
raisons mais est-ce que vous pouvez nous
renseigner là-dessus et nous dire
comment vous travaillez pour réduire ce
délai potentiellement parce que certains
nous disent on est presque l'arme au
pied mais on a cette difficulté y
compris pour convaincre nos
investisseurs qui nous disent mais si
nous n'avons pas le
raccordement dans un délai suffisant
finalement on va on va pas investir
alors effectivement
on les ont nous sommes
qu'on se à ce genre de problématique
et c'est la raison pour laquelle pour
des
projets comme le projet domo mais
également comme le projet Boréalis et
bien nous avons pris
la décision de demander
en très grande avance ce qu'on appelle
la fameuse proposition technique et
financière auprès de RTE puisque ce sont
des raccordements au réseau de transport
et non pas horizon distribution et donc
de pouvoir effectivement faire en sorte
que ça ne soit pas quelque chose qui
soit bloquant dans le déroulé de
développement du projet raison pour
laquelle nous avons pris le risque en
fait de demander et de payer en avance
de phase
l'édites études afin de nous assurer que
ça ne soit pas un point bloquant dans le
développement et la mise en oeuvre du
projet pour certains de ces projets ça
nécessite effectivement de Lourdes
études et également un débat public pour
certains d'entre eux donc c'est très
important effectivement de pouvoir
anticiper mais là encore
c'est un risque que l'investisseur prend
et typiquement ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que ce risque il est pris par nos
clients et par nous-mêmes
un complément beaucoup plus important ce
que vous avez raison ça concerne le
groupe et ça concerne des filiales de
groupe qui sont parfaitement
indépendantes et donc je peux vraiment
pas parler en leur nom donc enedis pour
les projets de taille
relativement modestes et puis RTE pour
les projets de fortes puissances en
revanche comme vous j'ai vu la
communication récente de RTE sur le
sujet il y a quelques semaines une ou
deux je crois qui appelaient à disposer
de moyens et aussi le géant faire
évoluer les règles donc je vais encore
une fois je peux pas parler à leur place
mais je pense que ça vaut la peine de de
que vous échangiez avec RTE et enedis
sur ce point parce que
c'est un point qui pourrait être commun
qui pourrait être évoqué aussi par
en revanche dans le groupe il y a une
autre filiale qui a besoin d'être
accordée beaucoup au réseau et
rapidement c'est la filière EDF
renouvelable qui développe des nouveaux
moyens de production et qui est
également de temps en temps fait face à
des délais un peu longs alors c'est pas
de la mauvaise volonté c'est que
simplement les le volume la quantité et
le rythme de nouvelles installations
soit de production des renouvelables
soit de consommation de l'hydrogène
augmente de manière très forte c'est
c'est la transition énergétique en
marche j'allais dire et beaucoup plus
rapide et dans des volumes beaucoup plus
importants que les années précédentes il
faut donc en tenir compte à la fois dans
les moyens et le cas échéant dans
certaines règles mais c'est des règles
de de financement ou de raccordement au
réseau dans un sens ou dans l'autre pour
lequel seul les opérateurs de réseau
sont légitimes à s'exprimer
pour conclure et terminer
il est évident que
avoir une vision globale de ces demandes
de raccordement et absolument nécessaire
avoir une vision de ces raccordements
sur le réalisme des projets et tout
aussi nécessaire
il me paraît absolument capital
de faire vérifier alors une fois que
j'ai dit ça je serai vous dire qui mais
à minima de nous assurer que lorsque un
projet est demandé en terme de
raccordement au réseau pour des
quantités astronomiques parfois y a-t-il
un vrai réalisme de derrière ce projet y
a-t-il des clients derrière ce projet
bien merci simplement par curiosité à
Auxerre c'est une c'est les transports
en commun c'est géré comment par qui
sous-traitée les Keolis derrière non je
donc à Auxerre nous alimentons les 7
premiers bus de l'agglomération de le
serois qui a une DSP une délégation
service public avec la société Transdev
et l'agglomération de l'océan donc
entend
substituer débuts additionnels jusqu'à
2025 à l'instar d'ailleurs du syndicat
SMTC de Belfort qui commence avec cette
premier bus et puis qui en ajoute
progressivement 20 etc donc ça commence
en général par un peu moins d'une
dizaine de bus soit par l'opérateur qui
peut enfin c'est différent ça peut être
Transdev Keolis le syndicat ça peut en
régie comme on vient de voir sur Belfort
donc mais souvent enfin quasiment
toujours
l'agglomération en question ou la ville
en question a prévu de de changer
progressivement l'ENT ièreté de sa
flotte en tout cas de certaines lignes
nécessitant une autonomie
un mode opératoire ou l'hydrogène et le
plus pertinent que la batterie
de complément par rapport à un point qui
a sous le rapporteur en début de réunion
en s'interrogeant sur le fait de savoir
si l'électricité le volume d'électricité
serait suffisant à terme pour couvrir
l'ensemble de ses besoins comme je
disais tout à l'heure on est en
plein développement de la transition
énergétique donc il faut toujours être
prudent quand on fait des scénarios vers
l'avenir ce que je tenais à dire c'est
que quand
EDF qui n'est pas le seul et même pas le
premier d'ailleurs à faire des scénarios
à long terme à 2050 c'est la mission de
RTE c'est la mission de l'État avec la
stratégie nationale bas carbone mais
quand nous faisons les nôtres également
on se on se base toujours sur une
évolution assez ambitieuse de la
mobilité électrique de l'électrification
d'un certain nombre donc là je parle de
mobilité électrique directe
d'électrification d'un certain nombre
d'usages industriels avec une hypothèse
de réindustrialisation
et on inclut toujours une part enfin
toujours pardon on inclut ce n'était pas
le cas il y a quelques années mais on
inclus depuis maintenant
au moins trois ou quatre ans de manière
assez croissante une part importante de
production d'É destiné
à produire de l'hydrogène électrolytique
ou d'autres ou d'autres camions de
synthèse à partir de de
d'hydrogène électrolytique mais c'est
bien prévu dans nos Sénats et quand en
face
on discute avec vous avec les
parlementaires et l'état de ce que sera
dans la future loi de programmation
énergie climat le les volumes de
production qu'il faudra mettre en face à
moyen long terme c'est bien saisi
peut-être de consommation que de notre
côté en tout cas on pose sur la table
qui inclut bien la production
d'hydrogène en quantité tout à fait
significative je vous dis pas qu'on a
une certitude à 2050
à 2% près sur ce que sera la part
d'électrification ou de consommation
d'hydrogène de la mobilité lourde ou de
l'industrie je crois que personne ne l'a
en est obligé d'être modeste et tout ça
est révisé périodiquement au moins tous
les 5 ans pour la loi mais nous aussi
bien sûr mais en tout cas on les intègre
d'ores et déjà on l'a vraiment bien pris
en compte et ça représente un volume
significatif on pourra vous le donner de
manière chiffrée dans les réponses au
questionnaire
oui c'était sur ce point que j'allais
vous vous relancer parce que ce qu'il
faut qu'on essaie d'apprécier c'est quel
est le volume en question et qu'est-ce
que ça permet comme perspective concrète
et réelle et étayée pour la filière
hydrogène c'est souvent ça
j'avais une discussion encore informelle
avec
enfin dans un autre cadre notre rapport
avec des personnes du ministère des
Finances qui suivent un peu ces
questions et spontanément ce qui vient
dans le raisonnement c'est toujours ce
point-là alors reviens au mystère des
finances ça vient chez les cyntanques ça
vient chez les experts c'est de nous
dire ah oui mais la limite c'est la
production d'électricité c'est la
capacité à affecter une partie de la
production d'électricité à l'hydrogène
et du coup ça capte le potentiel de la
filière ça c'est un point majeur qui
nous faut essayer de renseigner donc je
fais des éléments où maintenant ou
préparer écrit on est vraiment preneur
parce que ça absolument pas on voulait
transmettra sous le contrôle de cristal
je crois pas que ça capte
aujourd'hui évidemment parce qu'on est
au début du processus donc il y a pas de
manque d'électricité pour produire de
l'hydrogène il y a pas question qu'il y
en a à l'avenir et ça fait partie encore
une fois des hypothèses que l'on intègre
bien pour dimensionner le parc de
production tel qui nous pose appareil
nécessaire évidemment pas le seul
producteur même si on en est un très
important et qu'on espère bien le rester
mais il y en a d'autres notamment dans
le domaine du renouvelable mais c'est
bien c'est bien pris en compte dans nos
hypothèses de d'évolution de la
consommation
voilà et donc on vous transmettra
effectivement ces éléments là avec les
différents scénarios qui existent
Madame la Directrice monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur si je
puis me permettre une très courte
conclusion
vous l'aurez compris
ce n'est pas les montants qui sont en
jeu aujourd'hui
les ambitions affichées sont de belles
et bonnes ambitions en revanche ce qu'il
nous faut absolument réussir c'est
l'accélération du déblocage de ces fonds
publics
ils vont conditionner toute la création
de valeur de la chaîne
ils vont permettre aux industriels de
prendre des décisions d'investissement
en temps et en heure ils vont permettre
aux fabricants d'électrolyseurs de
devenir
en capacité de produire massivement
industriels
les électrolyseurs requis confère le
sujet concurrence dont on a parlé
compétitivité et ils vont nous permettre
de récupérer les informations le retour
d'expérience de savoir comment un
électrolyseur de 20 MW se comporte et de
pouvoir réagissez le tir le cas échéant
pour les autres installations qui se
sommeront en gigawatts
quand nous aurons réussi ça là nous
pourrons dire que nous avons un temps
d'avance et nous aurons ce temps
d'avance parce que nous aurons avoir pu
créer toute la valeur sur l'ensemble de
la chaîne de valeur
je vous remercie
nous qui vous remercions messieurs merci
de nous avoir accordé du temps et des
éclairages dans un sujet pas facile en
fait
absolument passionnant
merci beaucoup